yeah there's been there's a lot of
there's a lot of crazy stories like I'm
sure I don't even remember his parents
were [ __ ] super cool back then though
they have always let us lay back
cigarettes car yeah I still got a
cigarette scar nowadays but yeah it's
right that little circle right there
yeah how do you guys feel about when you
see a can of Milwaukee's best well I
have a drink once it's probably to be
honest with you they don't have the gold
tops anymore so don't the flashbacks I
used to yeah I mean I was just trying to
help you guys out you really did Elvis I
was going down the wrong path how did
that [ __ ] go how did that work okay so
uh I mean I was [ __ ] up back then too
you yeah so selling money from his
younger brother who's trying to score
some beer no like 16 17 I just started
an economics class in high school yeah
yeah so we asked you for beer and I know
it was you or somebody else
we're like go ask Jake Ford if you can
buy some beer we got like $20 $30 or
whatever yeah you come back and he's
like yeah he'll buy it for us but uh he
wants to put a cigarette out on her arm
and that's the only way he'll do it and
we're like [ __ ] no he's like well then
he's not buying the beer we're like all
right well [ __ ] like how bad could it
but I remember he comes over and he puts
the cigarette out of my arm and then it
like it boils up and then surprised then
he takes his thumb and he just rips this
it wasn't like you just put it out
that's something you just like and then
cool we're getting some beer but he
cinches it and it takes his thumbnail
and scrapes the [ __ ] skin ah it was
like four of us and then he contact with
me as he was doing Isaac really [ __ ]
up part about it was I was supposed to
get you guys a case of milwaukee's best
for 30 bucks yeah I show yeah and it was
nice yeah yeah we still got [ __ ] up on
that though for sure my parents found
the cans in the yard like ten years
later
if our parents ever ripped up that front
yard
those Palmetto playing set but with a
five man how'd even know like probably
Luke suits out there right Jesus Christ
like the McDonald's golden arches I just
tell people say I couldn't afford a gold
tooth so does it give me the whitest one
you got would actually be sick oh yeah
you should've got gold
[ __ ] you could always switch it up in
the future dude it's like a phone plan
no it's still in layaway yeah I got this
podcast just going about Luke's teeth
just growing up with me so walk us
through the walkers up to the actual
arrests how did that how did that what
led up to that okay so I got I got I got
yeah I got arrested in 2007 I was I was
driving somebody around we picked up
this crackhead in st. Pete that owed him
money and told us to drive to Seminole
that's where the money was that he had
at his house yeah so he tells us to go
to this house in Seminole pull up he's
like oh it's a house right there so
we're in the car we're not even really
paying attention to him yeah he gets out
and just [ __ ] books it but we don't
know that so they do dumb with just
[ __ ] he's like where's my [ __ ]
money I was like dude he left it's not
even his house
the dude [ __ ] is so mad we're all
[ __ ] up too so [ __ ] he gets out
he's yelling where's my money and now
we're in [ __ ] Seminole there's
[ __ ] kids I remember kids
playing so parents are [ __ ] watching
ya watchin this is like broad daylight
this is broad [ __ ] daylight middle
afternoon this dumb [ __ ] kicks
his [ __ ] door in okay
nobody was [ __ ] home thank God because
like it probably would have been like a
life sentence kind of deal so he gets in
in any [ __ ] grabs like a few shotguns
out of this house
yeah just ran into a random house a
random house that he that the dude told
him that he lived at but he didn't
[ __ ] live there right kind of deal so
he just wanted a ride or something
no he okay so we picked him up because
he owed that dude money yeah and he's
like oh we got to drive me to st.
Seminole to this house so I can get my
money or whatever what you never trusted
crackhead because the crackhead never
lose money anywhere yeah I know so it
ends up he ends up turning like okay
kicking in the door nobody's home
cool 30 degree third degree felony like
lowest felony hmm you grab guns you arm
yourself it's armed burglary which is
like a first first-degree felony
kind of deal right you brought the guns
are there guns no he's going out of the
house so so in Florida if you okay so
say you're like going in somebody's
house to go like burglar not home yeah
it's mean it's serious but it's not that
[ __ ] serious yeah you you steal a gun
from their house you arm burn on
yourself so you're that's it's our
burglar
so it's accident so again there with the
gun um no I mean that's actually a
little bit worse yeah but it's I mean
it's up there though to know so uh so
whatever we get we get we get popped for
that oh no ok so we get away they get my
license plate we focus a berserk yeah
the neighbors get the my license plate
cops come to my house they talk to me
what happened there they tell me to come
in and make a statement on this date I
go okay I never [ __ ] go never do a
statement it's like three months goes by
yeah nothing I'm like cool
you're good I got away Yeah right no no
no I'm [ __ ] cutting trees I'm uh I'm
I got on with some dude I don't even
know how I got the job but it was like a
tree service yeah so I'm just like
grounds dude whatever
[ __ ] up whatever yeah so I see they
these like three cars like put like
pulling off Indian Rocks Road at this
house and I was like damn let's call the
bad cops so then they they pull in where
the neighborhood real quick they turn
around they jump out and I start running
oh and I cut pills on me and I'm [ __ ]
eating them and then so they got their
guns drawn on me no so I get arrested
that day that was that was February 25th
2007 so I had to stay in the county for
eight months I ended up that was like
that was my first like getting in
trouble kind of deal so what do they
charge you with um the home I got armed
burglary you went in the house - I
didn't go in the house I was in the car
I mean that's how it goes that's okay so
if I'm like I'm like hey Danny drive to
the store real quick yeah Robin Robin
you Robin ice but you don't even know
and I get back in the car yeah you're
[ __ ] you're getting charged with
armed robbery right okay it's your
[ __ ] call you know so my parents
bailed me out
a week later right they bail me out a
week later you have you had eight months
no no I didn't do eight months on that
time I'm sorry okay I got I get a mixed
up oh yeah there's a lot of loose a lot
of [ __ ] show coming up okay so I get
arrested for that
a week later I [ __ ] finally convinced
my parents like you gotta let me out I'm
so [ __ ] like dope sick like I'm
hurting so bad suck everything [ __ ]
sucks and then so I get out [ __ ]
right back on it let's go hit the doctor
let's go do this and that so I'm running
around this [ __ ] other [ __ ]
we got a [ __ ] ton of pills coke we have
a ton of money on us and I got driving
this Cadillac Cadillac I know I have to
get gas yeah I keep [ __ ] forgetting
to get gas [ __ ] run out of gas at
parking Park Boulevard and Summa
Boulevard yeah okay that mobile is yeah
so this [ __ ] scrawny coked out
[ __ ] can't push a Cadillac right
okay so I have to get out and push it
he's got a suspended license so there's
a but there's a cop in the mobile
parking lot he goes you boys need some
help no I got it so we pushed the car in
and he's like oh because we look we look
[ __ ] do we look at that [ __ ]
he's like you so you know something's
going on yeah
these eyeball cast here IDs am i cooling
out here and then the dude gives him his
and he runs that guy okay so the car is
not actually running but he's driving
the car because I was back to the state
of Florida versus Fred Flintstone law I
mean okay early in the day we we bought
like these huge box of [ __ ] needles
and we're just shooting up all day and
throwing the ones behind us okay
in the co backseat of the car so there's
probably like 15 [ __ ] needles laying
in the back of the car on the floor so
and there's he threw coke under my seat
I had pills on me and so I end up
getting arrested that day so why because
he runs dudes up well he runs the guys
ID and since its suspended yeah he's got
probable causes to search my car right
he's driving yeah no questions about
yeah yeah so and the [ __ ]
through the coke under my seat too so I
got I got all the charges that day that
was another guy he got arrested like 20
times
never never did more than a couple days
in jail so it's a little fishy
ya know so that happens so it's a week
later so now I'm back in ain't nobody
[ __ ] bailing me out now so I had to
ride it out for like eight months I was
charged with possession of cocaine or
codone on that one
so then and that was one of the first
times I went and tom was through the the
video screen video chat yeah at the jail
on 49th I was like one of the the first
steps towards our relationship actually
being something like me and my mom
rolling up there and like talking to him
on that so pretty cute thank you I know
this high voice taking you back to those
times we could take that back to a cell
with you and tell your boys about it
sure is I appreciate all that [ __ ] yeah
so I [ __ ] ride it out for eight
months
[Laughter]